[Music]
hey everybody it's monday yeah we're
talking about another movie yeah we saw
this one last night
danny rowling says stellar movie choice
this is kind of like oh zach says jenny
where'd you find the music for the
starting soon screen it was either on
pixabay or on freesound.org
but i can't remember like what it's
called i'd have to like look up the file
i still have it somewhere this movie
here man
this is a weird one yeah
i always saw it like it you know at the
video rental store
but it was old when i saw it and i've we
never rented it
and uh
i
i don't know what to think of it it's
not a bad movie it's pretty good it's
trying to be kind of like uh the
exorcist or
um
the omen or something it's
it's trying to be kind of a high caliber
horror movie
except also kind of like really
irredeemably sleazy at the same time
yeah that's what's so weird about it
like the tone of it you can tell that
they were going for a little bit of a
more prestige yeah type of horror movie
but the subject matter
is very very sleazy and like very
exploitative remember what we were
saying the other day what were we
talking about when we said why were
there so many like monster rape movies
like right around this time period this
is one of the ones that's in that spooky
where have you been she just like popped
out of nowhere she fell asleep somewhere
she's like so she moved she was hiding
reported yeah i'm awake okay uh robert
kitchens asked if you were feeling
better
yeah i'm feeling better i'll be i'll
probably be you seem a lot better i'll
be a lot better tomorrow he actually
didn't cook today yeah i could do
something um i'll be a lot better
tomorrow though i'm just not
i'm not at 100 i'm probably more like
about 70
oracle says guess what i just picked up
off the porch tom and jenny's cookbook
happy dance oh that's awesome thanks for
getting me that yeah thanks for
throwdown said you had me at sleazy um
yeah the thing is it doesn't deliver on
it
i mean um
if they're gonna go this route there
better be some nudity there actually
better be some [ __ ] horror rape
scenes and there really aren't any in it
um it tries to do it but without showing
it to you
and it's here's the problem it's it's a
monster movie
the monster is actually not bad it's a
pretty good but you only see at the very
end and not for very long yeah rest of
time it's like or invisible or well
because it's structured like a mystery
yeah it's more like a mystery because
you're trying to figure out who it is
okay so the movie's called the incubus
or sometimes just incubus yeah now
this is not to be confused with i'm
pretty sure the chat william shatner he
did that movie remember he did that
movie in the 60s it was all at esperanto
no i'm pretty sure that that was called
incubus as well
yeah oh [ __ ] i don't know why i remember
that but um chet did a movie in
esperanto yeah of course he did
but yeah so
so it has nothing to do with that
this one
was actually based or was actually like
adapted from a novel by ray russell now
ray russell did a lot of stuff for
william castle i think probably the one
the thing that i knew him from was he
wrote a short story called sardonicus
and that's what the william castle movie
mr sardonicus was based on which is
actually not bad if you've seen it so he
wrote the novel and apparently the novel
was a lot more overt and a lot sleazier
because they had to kind of like dance
around a lot of things
uh in the movie i guess
and interestingly too maybe the reason
why
this movie has more of a prestige horror
type of like veneer to it is because it
was directed by um john howe i think
that's how you pronounce his last name
who also directed legend of hellhouse
one of my favorite uh horror films from
the 70s twins of evil the hammer film
you know the one with the boobs and well
that's all that's all of them uh watch
her in the woods i think that's [ __ ]
funny yeah it should have been like
[ __ ] quadruplets
and they both had boobs and you saw both
the boobs on both the twins
we did we covered that movie yeah they
were like hustler honeys weren't they
they were they were playboy they were
playboy or penthouse i came okay i'm
pretty sure they were playboy yeah but
yeah so this is the same director as uh
so he's done hammer he did legend of
hellhouse which like i said my one of my
favorite movies in the 70s watcher in
the woods dirty married crazy larry i
think he directed that as well so
you know this so this does have like
something of a pedigree and it stars
john cassavetes who probably most horror
fans know is like guy from um
rosemary's baby he was also in the fury
he's probably like i mean he was an
actor like for a [ __ ] [ __ ] he died
pretty young i think he was only 59
but um so he died like not too long
after this movie came out
but um he was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff and
he was a respected respected director as
well so i kind of feel like
i don't know that this movie it's
canadian
i don't know if that explains anything
but um
oracle said that yeah they have that
esperanto film
yeah we have it on dvd it's a trip to
see anybody trying to act and esperanto
i've always i've seen clips but i don't
think i've ever like sat down and
watched the home so curious oh that's
just gonna suck
for those of you who don't know what
they're talking about when when i was a
little kid they tried to come up with
some [ __ ] cockamamie international
language called esperanto which is a
mixture of like all the world's
languages i guess you know latin based
languages with english and spanish and
french probably all mixed in together
that [ __ ] went over like a fart in a
spacesuit [ __ ] nobody learned that
crap
well yeah and now like nowadays most
people just learn english
yeah well english wasn't the
international language back then french
was i remember when it happened fourth
time the internet came and [ __ ]
knocked that [ __ ] out of the park this
is no it's english
international language is english
but for now zach says how many shots are
in this movie of characters in a fog
filled room with shafts of light coming
through the windows because that's a
super 80s movie thing oh no not really
that many uh you'd be surprised but the
thing about okay so what this is about
an incubus and if you don't know what an
incubus is it's basically like a rape
demon right yeah it's a succubus but it
doesn't have titties
well the succubus is the same thing but
it's the female version exactly the
incubus is the male version
unfortunately apparently in the book
um and they kind of allude to this a
little bit in the movie but they kind of
can't really come out and say it i guess
even though they say some other pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ] but um
apparently in the book the incubus has a
big old schlong yeah well it was
rupturing everybody's uteruses some of
the girls survive it and they have to
take the uterus out kind of like you
can't fix a uterus i don't understand
that
but i think they probably could have
fixed it blew it up like a balloon
and then yikes sometimes leaving behind
semen and sometimes he's not and then
when he's leaving a whole bunch behind
god it can't be one man that's got to be
a whole group it's like a [ __ ] bucket
full yeah he goes and then it's red you
know was it blood no it's not blood it's
just what's weird is that it's a whole
investigation and yes and this is the
problem with the movie
is that you spend all this time
listening to these dudes trying to
figure out something that is plain to
you because the name of the movie is
they think of it so yeah you know
exactly what it is so it's kind of
if that's the case just [ __ ] show the
thing
yeah yeah i mean because you know what
it is you know [ __ ] so they should
have turned it into a a creature feature
and actually showed the [ __ ] monster
uh and showed it [ __ ] up women you
know messing them up
you know yeah it could be graphic i mean
there's rape scenes in this but they're
not
super they're not super graphic
and honestly it's almost kind of like
the monster is invisible
but then like you see him later just i
don't know
that's kind of yeah that's kind of like
the way they shot it i guess
but
it was funny because we were watching
this movie and tom is like about halfway
through he's just like man this entire
movie is people talking about [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah
i'm not gonna lie pretty much it yeah
but yeah so
it's on my [ __ ]
pretty much yeah well because grown men
talking about
zach you might like the [ __ ]
like i said it's a weird movie and it's
not a bad movie i kind of took a little
bit i mean you know this is a very
unscientific but i kind of like went
around to a couple horror channels i
like and this one seems very much in the
middle like some people just thought it
was
awful
um and some people thought it was kind
of like a lost gem
i'm kind of like in the middle it's it
had a lot of stuff that i really liked
about it it was kind of creepy it kind
of had
i liked the sleazy element it was kind
of like an original story i mean you
didn't really see a lot of stories like
this
um i saw one channel that was kind of
comparing it a little bit to like
nightmare and elm street three and well
just because the incubus
it's not just like a
loose ass incubus running around like
like raping people yes with a loose ass
yeah you know damn zack
yeah you think he'd give people lucy
at least that's giving you just go to
work on your powerbomb and stop
running around having sex with all the
fire hydrants
[Laughter]
but yeah so the thing about the incubus
is that he's apparently
tied to the dreams
of this weird teenage guy named tim
who's actually dating
the daughter
of john cassavetes character who is
uh whose name is sam what's his name sam
coldwell cold something i was trying to
ignore [ __ ] he was a surgeon yeah and he
was um so he lives in this town and like
yeah so there's this kid and like he
lives with his grandma
and
the grandma and then there's something
sketchy going on with the grandma too
like there's some witchcraft [ __ ] like
he has some dreams about somebody like a
woman being tortured to confess like
back in the witchcraft days
there's kind of like you know you know
what i think the main like i did like
this movie it was just like it was very
strange i think the main complaint is
that i have a suspicion
that a lot of stuff was explained in the
book that was left out of the movie
because i kind of feel like there's a
lot of stuff in the movie
that or a lot of kind of like plot
threads and stuff like that that don't
really go anywhere
like what was the deal with
i mean i guess i kind of get it but what
was the deal with dr sam like dr john
cassavetes what was the deal with him
and his wife being dead but like then
they imply that maybe he killed her like
accidentally
but then they don't mention that again
yeah because i was kind of like he has
like a flashback i'm like wait did he
kill her and then like they don't
mention it again and then like he starts
hanging out with this nosy newspaper
reporter who works and she's kind of
like looking into the case too and she
looks exactly like his dead wife
so i i don't know like the way it ends i
kind of get that but it seems like there
was a lot of [ __ ] that was left out and
then it seemed like they were trying to
wrap everything up at the end and it
kind of took me a second to be like wait
what
like what does that mean like i don't
know it's in some ways it's kind of
straightforward like you know that this
kid for whatever reason
um whenever he has a dream he doesn't
turn into the incubus
it's almost kind of like the incubus
is i don't know like it exists in the
world or something like that but it's
like it's
it's dormant until he dreams about it
and then like it pops out yeah it didn't
really make sense so i don't yeah it's
so i'm thinking that it's probably like
a lot clearer a lot clearer like it
delineated in the book i would imagine i
think it was kind of like um
i think it was kind of like that thing
on a forbidden planet where it's your id
it's like a satanic id when he's asleep
dreaming this thing it [ __ ] activates
and goes out and kills people some kind
of projection maybe
is that what it was that's kind of yeah
that's kind of what i was thinking evil
sexuality or something because it wasn't
anything i mean it was linked to him but
he didn't have to be there he just had
to be asleep and dreaming it was like
yeah because it was supernatural it was
yeah
and it had something to do with maybe
his mom was a witch
and that's who she kept seeing like
i don't know it was just really really
weird you just had to you just have to
have to understand the times in which
these movies were made you know what i
mean they would just pull something
directly out of the ass wouldn't he wash
it off
come up with some [ __ ] people
watching them watching she's gonna pull
that right just pull around the ass and
just just throw it right on the fence
this is how monster magic works you know
it just does this don't think about it
and maybe there maybe there was more to
it they got cut out that you know i kind
of think that's maybe what it was but
but they wouldn't it wouldn't have
mattered if it was in there it was one
it was that kind of [ __ ] a lot i don't
want to say they were dumb they were
just very expedient back then and they
had no problem just making up rules as
they were going on going along with any
of these monsters in these movies
oh by the way this thing's evil so you
know what that means oh well you can
kill it with silver bullets of course
yeah if you can kill a damn werewolf
then you can kill an incubus with silver
silver bullets i mean it makes sense no
sense yeah and it can't be out in a
daylight it'll [ __ ] you know so
what's a vampire now too you know it's
just
it's that kind of [ __ ] it's a
supernatural creature the same [ __ ]
works on all right right yeah so you
know hey when you're asleep it attacks
it's like the nightmare
yeah well i think that's why some people
were comparing it to like the nightmare
on elm street right thing because they
showed that painting the nightmare a lot
and it's like a yeah you know not the
one by henry fuselli but like another
variation of it
right
because i know there were a couple
others sitting on your chest while
you're asleep so it's just when they
just went down that direction and they
just said yes it happens when you're
asleep it kills other people ah yeah
that's the ticket they just make the
movie they don't think i mean mostly
it's a rape demon it would kill and it
rapes other people you're dreaming it
and it's raping other people
yeah yeah and the kid well the kid
didn't seem to
i mean he was kind of a spaz but it's
like he's yeah why him and why not
somebody else
it didn't make it it was him because his
mom was a witch so i'm
i'm assuming unless i wasn't paying
close enough attention
that the mom had
the reason she got um accused of being a
witchcraft was because she was
being a witchcraft of being a witch was
that she was indeed engaging in
witchcraft and
and had some and did you summoned the
demon so then when she had the kid
wait maybe was she raped by the incubus
so he's like the product of the witch
and the incubus maybe so okay maybe
that's what it was
so maybe that's why but he didn't seem
to be a bad person it wasn't real clear
because
the movie's not and that aspect of the
movie is not well fleshed out
they could have done something with that
but they didn't it you know what i mean
it was the movies of the time
this is kind of make that clear this is
kind of another i mean i only just now
like thinking about it it kind of works
that out yeah which goes to show you
that they did not make that clear in the
movie yeah and they didn't use that as a
plot point that could have been because
you could have done all kinds of cool
[ __ ] with that
but they didn't
because they didn't they didn't write
that way they didn't think that way well
like you said i kind of feel like what
they did it they couldn't really decide
if the movie wanted to be
like
a monster movie or a slasher demon
possession type movie or like a mystery
yeah because it seems like the first
two thirds to three quarters of it were
structured like a mystery yeah police
procedurally like a prison like almost
like or like a medical procedure all
kind of like because like i said um the
the demon was going around raping women
and most of them died like the first
girl survived but she was like so wigged
out that like she couldn't
talk about it she just said it was a
monster yeah and that's that's pretty
much all she said afterward and they
were just kind of like okay whatever but
then after that like basically the
monster would just like rape them to
death
and then they were getting all kind of
weird [ __ ] like the first rape is like
we didn't find any semen and then the
second one was like we have like all the
semen like buckets of the [ __ ] but it's
like red and weird and like swims really
fast devil semen is like devil seaman
right and then so and then like it kept
happening yeah and
so but i mean like you said the audience
knows that it's an incubus so it's like
they could have i like that aspect i
liked the mystery aspect
but and you know you can absolutely make
a good movie out of like a mystery movie
out of
something that the audience already
knows the outcome but you kind of have
to like keep it
i don't know keep that part like kind of
shorter yeah i kind of feel like it
would have been cooler if they would
have focused more on
the lore behind the incubus like where
the incubus came from because i feel
like they went a little bit into that
toward the end but not enough to find it
just felt very piecemeal there was a
movie made for tv movie
that kind of looked like this and was in
in some ways even better and delivered
more it's called gargoyles
yeah we reviewed that a while back
incubus is almost kind of like feels
like kind of like a cheap knockoff of
gargoyles and gargoyles was a cheap made
for tv movie but it delivered it showed
you the monsters quite a bit
and the monsters looked pretty good and
it also gave the story and what they
were trying to do and they got a lot of
the monsters running around fighting
people
this this movie really should have just
done that
they had a good monster it looked pretty
good it was about like on par what you'd
see out of gargoyles it looked kind of
like a gargoyle
it may have actually been from that
movie for all i know it did look kind of
look similar to it so they should have
just used that thing and [ __ ] shown
it more
and uh the movie probably went down a
lot better i would have simplified it a
lot and um
just i would have [ __ ] dropped most
of that
medical procedural investigation
that would have only been like maybe 15
minutes of the movie yeah i mean i liked
some of that i liked the character
development but a lot of it really
didn't need to be in there because there
were like some very long
shots uh you know some very long scenes
of like just
uh you know like dr sam and the
and the [ __ ] reporter lady yeah like
making out or some long extended scenes
with like between him and his daughter
um you know and you didn't really need
so much of that no this movie should
have been this [ __ ] demon running
around raping killing people and the uh
the the the cop and the doctor trying to
figure out where it was going to be and
how to stop it and how to destroy it and
what it was and what it was what it was
trying to do yeah the other thing was is
that the [ __ ] incubus didn't seem to
be trying to do anything just raping and
killing people
there should have been some kind of
higher purpose like you know bringing
the antichrist in
yeah you're right they didn't really i
mean the incubus maybe that's just how
incubus do yeah
but that doesn't make a good movie
that's what i'm saying yeah it's just
like well why is he doing it because
yeah just because should have been
should have been yeah this uh this this
demonic woman had brought it in and had
sex with it and they [ __ ] and and and
this is her son and her son is creating
it somehow in his dreams and its job is
to impregnate these women and give birth
to the antichrist that have been a whole
[ __ ] story right there
i thought that's where i was going
because okay what happened in the
beginning like the first i mean this
starts like right out the gate there's
like a couple like you know girl in a
bikini guy they're at a quarry and
they're swimming or whatever and
literally within five minutes
um she gets raped and he gets like
bludgeoned to death like with a big
stick with like a big nail in it or
whatever he's got like a big hole in his
head
so but she lives so i thought that the
incubus's whole
thing
was that he was gonna attack
if there was a dude there he'd be just
like kill him be like i don't need that
[ __ ] um but then he was gonna impregnate
the women
for whatever purpose i thought there was
gonna be a purpose like you said
but the weird thing about that was that
the first girl that got attacked the
only one that survived she they said oh
we didn't find any semen in there he
just blew her [ __ ] uterus out which
like i said that didn't really make any
sense either because
how come there was no semen in the first
victim and then the second one it was
just like a whole bunch of it you'd
think it would be like consistent
yeah and i yeah i thought he was trying
to like improve but then like from that
first victim like all the remaining
women were just killed outright yeah
like they bled to death we see you could
have the incubus just raping and killing
dudes because they're not women
yeah and then you have you know what i
mean that way you could have you could
have a bunch of scenes of people [ __ ]
dying but the women are living
yeah that's what how i would have done
it the women are living because he's
doing it to try to bring in the
antichrist type of deal yeah i thought
he was trying to impregnate or he was
trying to like make a new race of
incubuses or something that's what i
would have done i mean that's what i
yeah that's kind of what i would have
really he would have had need to have
had a reason he would have really upped
the stakes because then you have some of
these women and they actually are giving
birth right see that'd be awesome yeah
you can do all kind of gooey [ __ ] with
that
what comes out isn't human
you know it's like the baby from from
it's alive
[Laughter]
remember that one yeah that's oh yeah
yeah wait did we ever do that we've
reviewed that shirley we should we need
to talk about that one baby jumps out
just starts killing [ __ ]
killer baby yeah it's got fangs
i love it yeah and they had to chase it
down inside the storm dreams with the
ants with damage
you could fight it down in there little
baby
zach said uh maybe maybe the demon
jerked it before some of the rape so
there wasn't as much
yeah i mean if they explained that
discrepancy
then i missed it yeah i just thought
well that was kind of the whole like he
was impregnating them i was like oh he's
going to kill the dudes if there are
dudes of like there and then impregnate
the women for whatever reason but he
didn't like after the first one he just
killed i would have showed that demon it
had like a third leg just swinging and
when it was mad it'd get all the wreck
to come at you
well see that's what it was like that's
what it was like in the book
but i think they were i mean they were
afraid obviously you could you can't
show erect penises like in a regular
like it would be porn right i guess but
the thing about it is that because i
think isn't that still the dividing line
i'm pretty sure i don't know but um i
don't know if they've like changed the
rule since then but i feel like well
nowadays you can remake this
and just go full on you could still do
kind of like a classy movie but you
could do like trash classy i don't you
know what i mean make this [ __ ] classy
well no but i mean you could do
something like um
i don't know you could do something like
well they have that they have like all
this weirdo like european yeah
filmmakers that make like really really
sleazy like exploitative stuff but
they're still kind of like elevated
they're already going dancing don't know
who makes a video
don't wait
don't let him do anything
have we have we did we start watching
his did what did he do that movie
veronica or oh it's supposed to be
horrible
i saw like a clip of it and i'm like i
don't even think i could sit down
it looks awful like it's made with a
cell phone
poorly it does yeah and it just seemed
so
i don't know it seemed it seemed very
try hard yeah well [ __ ] glenn glenn
glenn can sing but he needs to stick to
one thing you know
yeah although they say he'd be doing
some comic books i don't know if they're
really good but well i think that's what
the movie was based on are they all
right so i don't know if the comics are
any good i've never read them but i've
heard that the movie was terrible and
like i said i've seen clips of it and it
really doesn't look good
um
yeah zach said lars von trier yeah
that's who i was that's what i was
thinking of like somebody like that
that or uh gaspar of nowhere wherever
you say his name like the people that
make these kind of like already films
but then there's like all this like
really really gory like sex and violence
and stuff like that i mean you could do
this concept
you could do it justice like i said but
they would need to i haven't read the
book i'd have to go back and read and
see like what what the book maybe the
incubus did have a purpose in the book
i'm not sure other than just like
running around raping people they missed
a bunch with it but here's the but all
in all man i gotta i gotta say it's not
a bad movie no i still enjoyed it it's i
mean if you're if you just wanna see a
retro
horror monster movie with a satanic
tinge to it you can see this you know
you're drinking and you're watching this
and you're watching this one because
you've seen all the other ones
you know what i mean yeah i just for for
some reason i had never seen this one i
kept i had seen it in the video store
like he's like the box art um but for
some reason i never rented it acting's
pretty good it's got a decent cast it's
just uh yeah now the guy that plays tim
the the guy whose dreams like bring on
the incubus he's a little over the top
yeah gonna say but everybody else in
this is good i'd still put shatner's
[ __ ] movie above this the one where
they had the damn [ __ ] ernest borgnon
no devil's reign devil's round yeah i
just talked about that today yeah well
yeah devil's reign is better better but
uh this one had a certain something
something there's just something about
that late 70s early 80s it's about the
tone like even when they're boring or
even when it's just like scenes of
people talking there's something like
some kind of creepy about them yeah and
i think this one had and this one
actually had some nice like like i said
this isn't um
you know this isn't some shitty like
fly-by-night director this is a good
director so there were like some really
nicely like framed shots in here the
score was really good um you know it's i
can see how some people might think it
was too boring i didn't think it was
boring but i thought they focused too
much on
the mystery aspect when they could have
focused more on like the gore and the
yeah figuring out
actions once well i mean once they've
determined
that
you know in the first 20 30 minutes they
determined this is not a human um we
don't know what it is but it's
definitely not human how we gonna fight
it how are we gonna stop it you know
that's then you could have done it from
there i feel like yeah i i think there
was some kind of conundrum where
they're trying to make this elevated
horror like like what zachary's saying
they're trying to make an elevated [ __ ]
on one hand but they got kind of like i
don't know
you
they went the wrong direction you
they're trying to make this elevated
horror this should have been an action
adventure horror
like
it should have been pretty fast paced
yeah as soon as it was revealed that
this isn't [ __ ] uh
it isn't uh isn't a human and that
you're dealing with a demon you could
immediately go into some into some
pretty cool adventures with this thing
because you got to find it yeah what
it's doing and figure out and there
could still be a mystery you could have
left it a mystery like who it was that
was controlling the demon like you could
figure out oh somebody's controlling
this and maybe we have to destroy that
person that like summoned it or whatever
so you could do that and there could
that could be the mystery yeah um yeah
something like that like you could make
it more a mystery like that like there
could be a bunch of people it's like
what it was trying to bring into the
world yeah or something like that like
you don't know that you don't know what
see there's all kind of stuff you could
do let's or you could do multiple things
you could do a bunch of those i would
have had it going on raping all these
women and it's giving birth to these
little it's alive monsters and you got
to have like a certain you've got to
have a certain amount yeah you got to
have a certain number of them because uh
once they're all born there's enough of
them to like perform a ritual to bring
this thing in yeah they have to have
like a coven like yeah
and then you know the witch is making
this special place where they're all
going to meet up
you could have a lot of fun with it but
you probably need the budget maybe they
didn't have the budget
yeah maybe not mango said cronenberg
would have done a good take on this
story i heard
that cronenberg was originally supposed
to do this because this is a canadian
film okay yeah um
[Music]
this would have been right up his alley
i mean this would have been
yeah
i think he would have made this like
more of a purpose
yeah it would have been a weirder [ __ ]
and i really really like it now one
thing we have neglected and i can't
believe you didn't mention this first
first thing what's that bruce dickinson
is it oh that's right i forgot about
that
so there's music being played different
every now and then and i'm like man that
that actually sounds pretty good you
know some of the [ __ ] that they're
playing and then they end up going into
this uh rock concert that's a movie
theater in a movie theater they're
having a concert and there's some kind
of weird
[ __ ]
fake satanic ritual like samson and
delilah or something you know
she's cutting off this guy's hair except
it's a wig it's a wig
and i'm going like man that sounds like
bruce dickinson and it turns out it is
bruce dickinson [ __ ] singing like he
was delivering man so i don't know what
band that was it was a samsung samson
okay okay that's why samson is alive
yeah
it was it's pre iron maiden yeah but um
yeah it was the trip to see him i had
and i'm looking at him we're good that
is bruce dickinson in there you know
that sounds like it and i'll check this
and it is him yeah we had to check like
because he's like oh my god that's
because he's pretty young
yeah i mean yeah this movie was 81.82
right right before he right before he
got into iron maiden yeah he was then i
looked it up because i was curious so i
was just kind of like yeah he was in the
band sampson for their first three
albums yeah um but he wasn't known
you're gonna love this he wasn't known
as bruce dickinson when he was in
sampson he was known as bruce bruce yeah
that's right bruce bruce that's creative
yeah
i will say too that in this movie like
the clip that they're showing like in
the movie theater that movie is called
biceps of steel
what
the movie that's showing i'm assuming
the one that had like things in it it's
called biceps of steel yeah but yeah
it's just like really funny how there's
this woman yeah it's it's yeah it's the
samson and delilah story so it's this
woman like over this other guy who looks
like he's was kicked out of anvil yeah
and um
she's cutting off and it's like a very
very fake yeah uh you know red
heavy metal wig yeah it was a trip to
see it but i didn't think much of it i
quickly forgot about it just in the
movie continued
because he just had kind of a little
[ __ ] walk-on roll walk on part on it
[ __ ]
but uh they i think they played a couple
of samson songs in the background like
the
girl was listening to something on radio
and um and she got killed it was almost
kind of like um
it was almost kind of uh goth almost
like uh goth metal kinda yeah it was
sounded almost like like a proto london
after midnight or something yeah kind of
a little bit of new wavy kind of
violence
that may have been samson i don't know
of any any of samson's music
but then what they showed was like when
they were up on stage it was like it was
like
[ __ ] what was it
what's the one where they were
what the [ __ ] was the name of that song
we had the we had the closed captioning
on so we could see the lyrics and i was
just like wow it's pretty yeah it was
kind of like um
uh
[ __ ] what what was that one
mockumentary about a rock band
looking it's final time i don't know it
sounded like something on a spinal tap
it did well everything from that era
sounds like spinal taps
that's why spinal tap is so funny
because i mean they nailed it yeah the
scene the scene with bruce dickens in
this movie is like so funny because they
had those what do they call those like
kind of uh the laser fields
it's just the laser beam that went in
it's a laser beam that goes like that
and then like when you stand in it
it's just like it looks like these
planes of lasers like coming at you and
i was just like ooh
high-tech [ __ ] it was it was like
you can remember a [ __ ] laser you own
your science because only your science
department had it at high schools like
that those things are worth thousands of
dollars a [ __ ] laser beam yeah now
you can get one for 50 cents on like the
end of a key chain down the [ __ ]
hardware store and have your cat play
with it yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
but uh yeah so this was where did we
watch this amazon prime yeah i think it
was free on amazon prime we just kind of
like clicked on it because i was like
here's one from the early 80s and i
haven't seen this one
it's better than a lot of other movies
from that time that's true that's true
like cue wicked serpents a lot better
than that oh i don't know i kind of have
a song for that one
i have a soft spot for that one i put it
up
i put it up there with uh
that's that [ __ ] shat movie
stella's rain the devil's rain yeah i'm
not quite as good as that but yeah yeah
this still has kind of like it's not
satanic necessarily you try to get that
look it has kind of like a demonic
witchcraft kind of like
vibe to it a little bit a lot of the
[ __ ] main things happen inside of a
inside of a uh
um
a museum that has a kind of a
like a medieval torture medieval torture
type thing so yeah they're just trying
to get that look yeah it does you know
so it had like some creep i really liked
the the set design i liked the inside of
the doctor's house i liked the museum
set because like the librarian gets
raped and murdered in a very strangely
edited scene yeah so
there's that like i said they didn't
show they got her [ __ ] nylons all
ripped up you're like well maybe this
maybe this is gonna look sexy now
mango says q rocks yeah i like i like i
didn't like you that much i like you the
wing it's urban well i like all names i
mean god told me to is probably my
favorite of his but um q is good too
but yeah so
this one is definitely i mean it's
definitely worth watching it's
definitely worth watching if you're into
this era and you haven't seen it you
know what i mean um you know john how
has directed like much better movies
like legend of hellhouse we've advancing
that one but you know it's still pretty
good um for tonight i don't know why i
just thought of this but there's
uh the movie that i've been wanting to
re-watch
and i just saw somebody mention it like
earlier today and i was just kind of
like oh yeah they have that for free on
tubey is
deadly blessing the wes craven movie
from the early 1980s
so maybe i'll watch that tonight and
we'll talk about that tomorrow because i
remember seeing that a while back and
that being pretty good but
i'm just i don't know i'm kind of like
in an early 80s
like sort of forgotten horror
mood
the last few days in case you guys
haven't noticed so uh so yeah so like i
said this is on amazon prime
if you have amazon prime you can watch
it for free let me know what you thought
about it because it seems a little i
don't know if i'd go so far as say it's
divisive but some people some reviews i
saw they they really hated it um and
then like two canadian guys i like
there's two there's this really funny
channel i can't remember what it's
called but it's two canadian guys
they're like super canadian and uh they
do kind of similar to what we do we they
just kind of like sit in their little uh
parlor or whatever and they drink beer
and they say like what they're drinking
and then like they talk about
cheesy horror movies and they were
talking about this one they were excited
because it was canadian but they were
like really really into it so i don't
know uh all right mango says deadly
blessing is fun yeah i remember liking
it but i haven't seen it for a long time
and i've been wanting to rewatch it
mango says god told me too is coming on
shutter this month yeah it's on there i
saw it uh we've already covered it so we
probably won't cover it again but yeah i
saw that they had added it last thursday
i think they added it all right so
that'll do it for today i guess thanks
everybody for dropping by and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow bye